Concern about the teaching critical race theory
in schools is percolating around the country,
but at this point, a lot of Americans aren’t
familiar with the term.
A June 2021 Morning Consult/Politico poll found
that 51 percent of registered voters had not
seen, read, or heard anything about it.
A June Fox News poll found that 41 percent
of registered voters were not very or not
at all familiar with it and another 8 percent
had never heard of it.
Among those who knew about it in the Fox News poll,
37 percent said it should be taught in the public
schools, but 43 percent were opposed.
In the Morning Consult poll, 32 percent said
it should be taught in K-12, with 36 percent
opposed.
Americans don’t want to sugar-coat US history.
In a July Reuters/Ipsos poll, more than seven
in ten favored teaching high schools students
about slavery and its impact, and separately,
about racism.
But many are clearly concerned that critical
race theory goes far beyond an even-handed
portrayal of the country’s past and present.
Should critical race theory be taught in schools? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.